what is the lie that tells the truth the
line that tells the truth is the comic
premise it's uh you're you're
constructing a lie in order to get to
the truth of something uh how can you be
a good person in the world well you know
maybe you wake up and you
um you you do good things and maybe you
work for a non-profit and you if you see
somebody homeless maybe you give them a
dollar
but not very amusing
so you create a lie to get to that truth
and so you start off with somebody who
uh is not a good person in the world
um as in Groundhog Day and he go and you
then you there's this LIE there's this
impossible thing that happens or
improbable thing that sends him on a
journey in which
the the question that you're that you're
pondering is explored
because it's ultimately For Me theme is
best expressed as a question
um as opposed to love you know uh theme
of Romeo and Juliet love conquers all
maybe but don't they both die at the end
I mean so so that seems the theme is a
postcard it's not as useful to you as
theme as a question because in Romeo and
Juliet maybe Shakespeare is exploring
what's the nature of love because you've
seen Romeo and Juliet all sorts of
different sorts of love there's the love
of Romeo for his Bros Benvolio and
Mercutio there's a love of Juliet for
the nurse there's the malicious
um you know kind of uh grasping you know
love if you can call it Love of tibult
the evil the evil cousin uh for for
Juliet because he wants to control her
and not have her see Romeo so there's
also different sorts of love
so you're exploring a question that
you're taking
the time to explore in your writing as
opposed to you know the answer
and now you're just you know kind of
connecting dots because maybe you don't
know the answer how's how's that maybe
maybe it's just something you're
thinking about and you're not sure and
so by you by using this narrative you're
exploring it yourself
otherwise it's it's you know four months
to six months of hard work and you
already knew where you're gonna go
um a lot of uh script uh books tell you
you should always know where you're
ending up
but even that's not always true and not
every great writer writes that way if
you're going to write a mystery again I
think you should know who killed who
killed the guy or the girl at the
beginning
um but I think it's important to
observe the passing moments in comedy
because that's where the comedy comes
from not from I need to get from here to
here but what's happening here and look
around and wow that's weird and if you
if you're just writing from here to
there you're going to miss the weird
thing that your character
with their eyes notices and with their
mouth says something about it or does
something about it
so I think that's more useful so the lie
that tells the truth is your basic comic
premise that is the gateway to exploring
the truth of whatever you're whatever
you're talking about whatever your theme
might be
so to go back to the the initial idea
for the film The person works at a
non-profit uh they're they're kind to
the homeless and we could spice it up if
there was an actual purpose to that
Journey maybe okay here's a person
um they say they're they're they're
um
uh they work in a non-profit they're
kind to the homeless they they they they
drive they they drive a you know a Prius
they they only eat gluten-free and let's
say they win the lotto and they win
four you know what was what was that
that prize that was there a couple of
months ago
um I think it was like a billion two
billion dollars and they win two billion
dollars
will it change them
how will it change them what will happen
what will happen to their preconceptions
to their Notions
now if nothing happens I would say well
you have the wrong character
because you want a character who's going
to go through a transformation
so so uh that's you know that's why it's
not just come up with a funny idea and
then run with it well who's the
character that's going to go through
that
WTF that what the [__] moment uh and and
how do they how do they need to go
through that what the [__] moment and
and what are you saying about them and
what are you saying about the nature of
whatever it is you're writing about the
nature of
so what I'm curious that'd be
interesting Arc so maybe they get all
this money and it changes their
perceptions maybe they thought wealthy
people were evil and then they come to
find out oh they're not so bad after all
and then they become the very person
they despise maybe you see that that's
that's the joy of of writing and
developing an idea is that you is that
when I do these workshops
um uh I used to do them in you know live
uh in Tel Aviv and Mumbai now I'm doing
them uh on zoom and I don't think I
don't think people ever want to get off
Zoom I think they want to get off Zoom
but I think it's like why do I have to
fly to Los Angeles to take this Workshop
I can just turn on my computer so anyway
um I I would say there would be let's
say 25 people in the room
if you came up with that idea
woman Works in non-profit wins the wins
two billion dollars in the lotto
there could be 25 different ways of
developing that idea each of them valid
there's no one way to develop a premise
it's the premise is just a tool it's
another tool to to help you uh help you
excite the imagination to develop the
story in your head
but in some sense that Arc will come out
the other side though yeah it should it
doesn't doesn't need to I mean uh if if
the let's say there's a guy and at the
end of the movie She's together with the
guy so that's a mainstream movie or
let's say at the end of the movie The
her and the guy go different ways so
it's an indie movie
right
so so it could be either it could be
either way sure that's true and she's in
therapy for the rest of her life and
maybe uh you know so so nothing is
predetermined nothing is predetermined
other than
you know if you need 400 you know 400
million dollars to make it well then
that's you're going to have to make
compromises in order to get 400 million
dollars but if you can make it for 40
000 you can just do anything you want
the I think the point is is that
whatever the idea is whatever the LIE is
you're using it
in in the
Enterprise of finding out the truth
about something
for yourself first before an audience
because if you think you know what the
answers are
why are you wasting time writing a movie
you know why don't you just go out and
change the world I I think I think most
people
wonder what the answers are at least
most Comics wonder what the answers are
and use narrative as a way of trying to
figure that out
how do you know if your comedy idea is
too far-fetched I think it's only
far-fetched if
if you
can't
if somebody can't relate to it
um
what's the movie everything all at once
oh yes everything everywhere all at once
everything everywhere all at once what
could be more confusing than everything
everywhere all at once except for the
fact that it was my relationship they're
talking about
and I'm going oh my God I understand
exactly what they're talking about
because it it Not only was great sci-fi
and mind bending and and full of all
sorts of you know you know
multi-dimensions but it was also about
you know
honey look at that you know the guy with
the waistband and waist pouch that's me
you know um uh so so far-fetched is only
means that somebody isn't able to relate
to it
and you only need one person to relate
to it uh how many you know how many
rejections did uh did they get did she
get for Harry Potter
um you know all you need is is one
person
on the other hand
work on something else at the same time
because because the one thing you don't
want to do is to flog the same horse
um that that the time that you're
spending trying to convince the world
that this is a great script you could
use some of that time to write your next
script because because every successful
writer will tell you that first script
helped me write the the seventh script
that sold
as opposed to you've got to buy this
first script I mean that's where a lot
of beginning writers end up with they
they White Knuckle that one script
and they won't let go of it and they
don't progress because listen
maybe it's not good maybe it's too
far-fetched to sell but maybe it's a
good writing sample what's your next
idea
so I'm thinking of the idea of Normie
you know I've been watching Wednesday
Adams and so they talk about these
normies and for anybody who ever I
haven't watched it yet but okay okay but
but yeah I have a vague idea what you're
talking about sure and so what if some
people aren't writing quote unquote
Normie comedies
which is for the mainstream which is
going to be seen at a Cineplex which is
going to be seen uh more in a area where
you know people's lives are pretty set
there's not it's it's not like this
crazy sort of eclectic group
and that that'll be my term for Normie
and and what they're writing is too too
far-fetched too absurdist well there's
something for everybody but that's weird
because because what I've heard
were that uh were that buyers were
looking for something that was edgy that
wasn't norming
and again
you have you have some executive saying
I want something edgy something that has
no one has seen before but what they
really are thinking but that I've seen
before so that it's it's comfortable
enough for me to sell it to my to my
bosses
so
it's like chasing a joke you you know
you all you can do is
is have one eye in the market or maybe
uh half a you know a half an hour maybe
half your ear on the market and then
write your story
and if they don't like this one then
write another one and be inspired by the
things that you like
the the Monty Python used to talk about
the fact that they were inspired by the
Goon show which was this uh radio comedy
on in in UK in Britain
they didn't steal it but they were
certainly inspired by it they were you
know kind of the you know they were the
children of the Goon show and uh SCTV
was inspired by Monty Python so what
inspires you go and if you're not
inspired by anything go find something
to inspire you and then what's your
point what's your take on that how do
you want to advance that conversation
so nothing is too far-fetched what what
there is is
something needs to be relatable
so in other words
uh some a writer once came up to my
friend Michael Hague uh who's a script
consultant and he wrote you know how to
sell your stories in 60 seconds and if
you can sell your story in 60 seconds
that's a good that's a good skill
um
but uh a person came up to Michael and
said I've got a script that that you
know that no nothing there's nothing
like this ever that than this script and
Michael said well maybe there's a reason
for that
meaning that you know if something's so
weird and unaccessible that maybe that's
why people aren't aren't collaboring for
it because they don't know how to access
it they don't know how to connect to it
or relate to it so if you're sharing
something about your life
even if it's through the prism of
everything everywhere all at once
then that's relatable
it's you know it's it's a family it's
it's a relationship that that literally
is gone off the rails and and it's going
to destroy the entire universe but our
families are our universe
so when our our families go off the
rails that's what it feels like so it's
a metaphor
so so even though all the
multi-dimension dimensional stuff is a
lie the truth is
you know our families are our universe
and and we need to we need to protect
them
as well as protect the universe from the
altar you know bad Lord